e
e,
шановні пані та
панове, вітаємо вас на інавгурації
проекту «Навички для відновлення» кваліфікована
робоча сила для відновлення
України, який є проектом, який реалізує
jazad, і
відразу на початку деякі правила домашнього вжитку,
щоб потенційно врятувати наші життя та забезпечити
нашу безпечну роботу, якщо ми почуємо
сповіщення про ракетний удар, ми прямуємо прямо до
підземного укриття, нам
допоможуть потрапити туди, і ми
матимемо для цього невелику перерву,
але, можливо, ми зможемо продовжувати
працювати там без прямої трансляції,
і ми відновимо нашу повномасштабну
роботу після  сповіщення, і те саме
стосується тих, хто дивиться нас на Facebook
YouTube Mya
Zoom, якщо ви чуєте сповіщення у своєму
місці, будь ласка, перейдіть у безпечне
місце робоча мова цієї
конференції українська та
англійська у вас є навушники та ви
можете вибрати один канал для  Англійський
канал два для
української мови Я б настійно порадив навіть
тим, хто добре володіє обома
мовами,
послухати усний
переклад високого рівня, наданий висококваліфікованими
перекладачами, і знову
ми збираємося
почути багато спікерів і, ну, ми збираємося
провести панельну
дискусію  Ви матимете можливість поставити
запитання спікерам і почути їхні
відповіді, будь ласка, познайомтеся з Яєю та Олександром,
це дуже важливі люди, вони будуть
носити
мікрофони, і я
наполегливо раджу їм тримати мікрофони
в руках, тому що ті, хто бере
їх говорити, неохоче  поверніть їх
зараз, тема сьогоднішнього дня дуже
важлива, правила внутрішнього розпорядку було
оголошено, і я думаю, що настав час для
вітальних
промов користувачів, які налаштують нас на нашу
сьогоднішню плідну роботу. Я хотів би надати
слово зараз заступнику міністра
освіта і наука України,
будь ласка, доброго ранку, вітаємо
всіх, раді бачити багато знайомих облич
з усієї країни, дякую, що
прийшли сюди, що є частиною
проекту. Я хотів би почати з
подяки нашим партнерам
уряду Німеччини Європейському Союзу J  для
кожного, хто робить внесок у
реалізацію проекту, для мене завжди складно
виступити з вітальною
промовою, а не дати якусь
конкретну відповідь на конкретне запитання,
але все ж я хотів би скористатися цією
нагодою, щоб сказати вам, що для мене
особисто головне  Територія
діяльності проекту є надзвичайно важливою, як
і для нашого міністерства, і є
кілька причин,
тому, по-перше, ми віримо в те, що ми
представили це прем’єр-міністру,
президенту України, ми представили
територію проекту  перед
Кабінетом міністрів, ви знаєте, що наша освіта має
відігравати набагато більшу роль у плані
навчання дорослих у плані навчання внутрішньо переміщених осіб
для ветеранів, для тих, хто бажає перепродати
себе, і поки що мало що зроблено в
цій сфері урядом,
міністерством та  ми хочемо
це змінити, по-друге, це стосується співпраці з
міністерством економіки, коли я прийшов на
посаду і став відповідальним
за професійно-технічну освіту та навчання,
цей вид співпраці став
для нас стратегічно важливим, ви знаєте,
співпраця зі службою зайнятості
з  Міністерство економіки має
першочергове значення, коли ми рухаємося
до того, щоб наша освіта краще
відповідала їхнім вимогам
ринку праці. Я сподіваюся, що ми зможемо
зробити це спільними
зусиллями, дякую,
Деметра, я думаю, що ви зробили це дуже
змістовним
і дуже захоплююче, але моє перше
запитання: ви набір знайомих облич, це
добре чи це
погано, з одного боку, ви знаєте людей, з
іншого боку, є вузьке коло
тих, кого ви
добре знаєте, може бути одним із
місць U Wick  будь-яка зустріч, коли ви бачите
забагато знайомих облич, я вважаю, що
насправді проект мав бути
набагато
більшим, тому що якщо ви бажаєте
запровадити деякі масштабні зміни по всій
країні, можливо, цього буде
недостатньо, але якщо ви хочете побудувати якусь
системну  речі, щоб збільшити їх пізніше.
Завжди краще робити це разом
із людьми, яких ви знаєте, тих, кого я
називаю знайомими обличчями, тому що, безперечно, це
ті, хто готовий працювати
разом як команда, щоб досягти
результату. Дякую, справді дякую  у нас був
менеджер з Міністерства освіти
і науки України, який логічно
привів нас до продовження, будь ласка,
вітайте Рамана Паклінського, директора
департаменту зайнятості населення
Міністерства економіки УК
України, доброго ранку всім доброго
ранку міжнародним партнерам, ну
проекту
Тана Берна, заступник міністра економіки
мала б говорити тут замість мене,
але, на жаль, вона захворіла, тому я
маю честь звернутися до вас із
цією вітальною
промовою. Україна
стикається з величезними
викликами, е-е, велика гуманітарна
катастрофа, спричинена
війною, ми не знаємо, коли вони  катастрофа
закінчується і як виглядатиме ринок праці після закінчення періоду
ми звернулися до МОП та деяких інших
організацій з проханням надати їхній
прогноз розвитку нашого ринку праці
на найближчі періоди, і
отримані дані були досить
різними, але є деякі загальні
показники,  скажемо, що ринок буде
добре розвинений, і для післявоєнного
відновлення нам знадобляться кваліфіковані
професіонали, ну, цей
проект завдяки нашим міжнародним
партнерам, німецькому уряду,
GED, Європейській
комісії, він
сприятиме майбутньому відновленню
України,
оскільки також  Допомагайте надавати
людям нові
навички та нові можливості працевлаштування,
щоб навести вам приклад зі
списку Шиндлера, один із моїх улюблених
фільмів, коли понад тисячу людей
врятувала лише одна людина, Оскар
Шиндлер, ви можете пам’ятати момент,
коли ці люди були
співбесіду, і відповіді були
такими, що я
піаніст, а Шиндлер сказав би, що
це хороший
металообробник, я думаю, це може нам
щось сказати, що нам доведеться переглянути
наш ринок праці вимоги до робочої сили
навички, необхідні для
відновлення
Україна, ті люди, які залишилися тут і
повернуться в Україну після війни,
зможуть краще адаптуватися до української
економіки після завершення вашого проекту,
тому велика подяка від міністерства
економіки, дякую, Роман, у нас був Роман
Поні з міністерства економіки  Сполученого Королівства
Україна тепер єн Адам координатор
кластеру сталого економічного розвитку
gsz спілкується з нами через GS через
Zoom доброго
ранку шановні заступники міністрів шановні
партнери колеги та друзі гм
підтримка економічного відновлення
України є пріоритетом для федерального
уряду Німеччини від імені
Уряд Німеччини, який підтримує
стабілізацію української економіки та
створення фундаменту для зеленої цифрової
економіки в центрі Європи з
низкою проектів, серед яких ЄС для
бізнесу, я просто Мін,
я дуже радий бути частиною
стартової події  для нових
навичок проекту Recovery, який фінансується
Федеральним міністерством
розвитку економічного співробітництва Німеччини,
проект як такий підтримуватиме вибраних
постачальників навчання для навчання
водіїв та
механіків будівельників як прикладів, які потрібні
для відновлення України та її
економіки, оглядаючись назад  у нашій співпраці
щодо професійно-технічних працівників з
2017 року G підтримує професійно-технічну
освіту та навчання в Україні та
досяг таких важливих
досягнень, як наведені нижче. Ми
підтримали понад 300 професійно-технічних
шкіл в Україні у збереженні їхніх
освітніх
програм, незважаючи на війну, вони
отримали генератори це  обладнання та
підручники для цієї мети ми
забезпечили навчання та подальшу освіту
для понад
5400 осіб, що дало їм змогу
активно формувати майбутнє та
брати участь у
зусиллях із відбудови. Ця підтримка була особливо
корисною для внутрішньо переміщених
осіб, ВПО, яким довелося облаштувати нові
домівки після втечі з  homes
Я хотів би подякувати Міністерству
освіти і науки та Міністерству
економіки за успішну початкову
фазу цього проекту та побажати всього
найкращого для початку реалізації.
Щиро дякую, дякую,
J Adam з The JS at був з нами
і настав час представити
сам проект, навички для відновлення,
будь ласка, вітайте людей, які мають велике
значення для самого проекту,
вітайте Мела Паулу, директора проекту та
Алексі Алекса, радника проекту, будь ласка, по
черзі або обидва
разом, я думаю, ми завжди
раді, що  будьте частиною цієї
технічної спільноти, я думаю, що нас
приблизно 150 людей по всій країні, які
просувають реформу професійної освіти та
навчання вперед сьогодні, ми
хотіли б представити вам нові
навички проекту для відновлення, і перш ніж Alexa
вникне в деталі, які я хотів би
взяти  ви подорожуєте в часі, як все
почалося, це було в грудні 2022 року, ми бачимо, як
директор професійно-технічної освіти та
навчання Інен Шумі
інтенсивно обговорює, як мають виглядати навички для відновлення.
З нами всі були
представники nqa
міністерства економіки, гм  державна
служба зайнятості і навіть
регіон Ріва разом з нами в
Берліні, я все ще пам’ятаю, що це були важкі
часи, особливо для KF, гм,
у ці дні відбувалися щоденні напади, вночі в місті було
темно, багато відключень, і я все
ще пам’ятаю ту Арену  був змушений
йти ногами вниз на 14 поверхів, щоб дістатися до
таксі та поїхати до Берліна. Це був
час, коли ми прийняли стратегічне
рішення про те, що наступна
програма професійної освіти та навчання має
розглядатися на тему навичок для
відновлення, це стало основою для нашого
пропозицію Федеральному міністерству
економічного співробітництва та розвитку, і
9 липня міністерство дало нам
доручення, і це було відправною
точкою для найкоротшого початкового періоду, який
я коли-небудь бачив.
Я чесно кажу вам, і я хотів би
подякувати  команда міс pesna та mro
zagori, що за два з половиною місяці ми
визначилися з пріоритетними секторами, 14
кваліфікаціями, які підтримуватимуться
проектом, шість фокусних регіонів, і
навіть цей список пілотних
шкіл з 20 пілотних шкіл
готовий  і з цією подією ми готові
піти, і ще раз дякую обом
міністерствам, щоб зробити це
можливим в останні дні я мав
можливість мандрувати
Україною, і професійна освіта та
навчання завжди стосуються батьків,
вчителів, молоді, дорослих, які  потребують
перенавчання, але я думаю, що нам потрібно
визнати, що Україна перебуває в
іншій ситуації, і під час
круглого столу у Венці я зустрів Василя у
жовтій сорочці, він є директором
компанії avora um із великою кількістю
різних роздрібних магазинів
країна, з якою він зараз стикається One
Challenge Персонал М, зокрема зі
складів, мобілізований, він не може
прийти на роботу, і жінки беруть на себе
цю роботу, він змінює процедури
всередині компанії, менша вага, але
йому також потрібно перенавчати молодих своїх
жінок  гм взяти на себе це завдання, і
це величезний виклик для організації,
і він сподівається на партнерство з
постачальниками професійно-технічної освіти. Наступна людина, яку я також
зустрів у Венці, це Анна, а Анна є власником
perfetto гм, це компанія, яка  виробляти
торти та гм морозиво гм, і вона
займається величезною франшизою їй випала
доля двічі переселити свою компанію,
вона створила її у злочині
переїхала з Kia на Kon, а
минулого року переїхала зon на V, і вона
постійно вона ніколи не втрачає  Сподіваюся, що
планує далі розширити свою компанію,
і вона також з нетерпінням чекає
співпраці з кимось, щоб навчити її майбутніх
співробітників, вона відкрита навіть для навчання молоді
в паві. Я зустрів іншу людину,
її звати Катаріна, зараз вона
виконувач обов’язків мера Пенсільванії,
вона працювала  на нульовій лінії фронту
в bmud як парамедик протягом одного року, і
з цим досвідом вона зараз є
сильним прихильником інтеграції
учасників бойових дій EXC, і я ніколи в
житті не бачив, щоб хтось мертвий палко
говорив про професійну освіту та
навчання, вона каже, що це  шлях
колишнього учасника бойових дій до перенавчання, пошуку
роботи та реінтеграції в
суспільство. Я думаю, що ці троє людей
трохи показують нам, як
змінюється середовище нашого проекту, а також те, як проводиться реформа в
Україні, ми повинні враховувати це  нові
потреби загалом наш проект буде
реалізовано до кінця
2026 року, і він потребує врахування цих моментів
лише кілька основних фактів про Україну,
і я думаю, ви всі знайомі,
минулого року стався величезний економічний
шок, чи впав ВВП  на 30%, але
Роман вже згадував, що
всередині також спостерігається стабілізація, і
є кілька секторів відновлення, які вже
знову ростуть. Ринок праці все ще
виглядає недобре, але гм. Виклик у
майбутньому полягатиме в тому, що
доступних людей буде дедалі менше
ринок праці, тому що Україна стикається з
серйозними демографічними проблемами. В Україні
старіє суспільство. В Україні
понад 7 мільйонів біженців у Європі, у
вас є шість мільйонів переміщених осіб всередині
країни, і, звичайно, в країні стає
все більше вразливих груп, таких
як EXC  competant
та інші. Я вважаю, що ця історія
дуже важлива, щоб зрозуміти, як
були структуровані навички для Recovery безпосередньо
перед тим, як я передаю Alexa. Я хотів би
надати трохи фактів
про проект,
хм, тому ми фінансуємося Федеральним
міністерством  економічне співробітництво та
розвиток. Нашою метою є
підтримка обох міністерств у створенні
міцнішої основи для підготовки кваліфікованої
робочої сили для процесу відновлення. Наш
бюджет становить 10 мільйонів євро, і ми
реалізовуватимемо проект до червня
2020 року, шість, я думаю, три основні
заходи, які ми маємо  планування, і ви
вже зрозуміли, що
перенавчання дорослих стане
справді центром нашого проекту, і ми
будемо працювати над тим, щоб озброїти
дорослих навичками та знаннями,
необхідними для того, щоб вони могли зробити свій внесок у
процес відновлення. Другий момент полягає в тому, що
вони, звичайно,  все більше і більше
вразливих груп, вони слабкі
в суспільстві, як активізувати їх для
ринку праці, щоб вони також могли зробити свій
внесок у процес відновлення. Я
думаю, що ми ніколи не повинні нехтувати та
ігнорувати те, що в країні все ще багато
молодих людей  ця країна, для
кого професійна освіта та навчання
є перспективним шляхом кар’єри, і ми
також будемо працювати над цією темою, тому я думаю, що
нам потрібно трохи подолати
тему того, як ми можемо підтримати дорослих,
уразливі групи, але все ж
молодь, будь ласка  дозвольте мені взяти участь у цій
ініціативі та продовжити
презентацію нашого проекту. Я спробую
детальніше пояснити, як
розроблено впровадження, що дозволить вам приєднатися до
мейджору, щоб приєднатися до реалізації
основних цілей нашого проекту як г-н
Мікель
Пауло  описав проект як такий, що
зосереджений на деяких найбільш важливих
аспектах, але це також дозволить нам
збільшити вплив проекту
та екстраполювати його на всю
територію України, оскільки було зазначено, що
війна змінила суспільство на
ринку праці  в усіх регіонах України, тож
ми маємо вирішити цю зміну в першу
чергу, з іншого боку, ми
успадкували щось із минулого,
ситуацію з довоєнного періоду,
тому проект складається з кількох
компонентів, тому одна з
Компонентами є
зміцнення інституційних рамок
ринку праці для професійного
навчання, щоб дозволити організаціям
працювати з цільовою аудиторією.
Другий компонент проекту спрямований на
розвиток навчальних та
освітніх програм, а також
розроблення професійних  підготовка
та перепідготовка інституційно,
розробивши програми ulent, ми маємо
спроектувати ресурси, гм, правильно витрачати
та адаптувати робочу силу до
попиту на ринку праці, і врешті-решт уся
архітектура проекту увінчається
четвертим компонентом, е-м,
цим  е-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-мм-м-м-м-м-мм-м-м-мм-м-м-мм-м-мм-м-мм-м-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-м-м-м-мм-мм-м-мм-м-мм-мм-м-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-мм-ммм
співпраця з нашими
партнерами. Я хотів би ще
раз подякувати всім нашим
партнерам, тому, розробивши цю
архітектуру, ми продовжуємо працювати в
тому ж напрямку, тому ми назвали
пріоритетні сектори для розвитку
освітнього сектору Великобританії, перш
за все,
реконструкції  і відновлення та
відбудова України, таким чином, буде
реконструкцією, другим, звичайно, буде
сільськогосподарський сектор, який є головним
пріоритетом для України, е, четвертим
сектором буде сектор послуг,
тому що ми очікуємо потреби та попиту на
перенавчання та адаптацію для
вразливих верств населення  групи населення,
звичайно, ми не маємо багато часу на
довгостроковий процес, тому
з нашими партнерами ми обрали
шість регіонів для
реалізації проекту, які охоплюють всю
територію України, тобто від
Західної України до  Центральна Україна та
Східна Україна, і кожна з цих
частин мають різну
ситуацію, гм, робоча сила,
компанії, тощо, і разом з нашими
партнерами ми спробували зробити
прогноз, які
спеціалісти будуть найбільше попитом у
кожному регіоні, звичайно, зараз гм
невизначеність в Україні не дозволяє
передбачити дуже точно, проте ми
спробували спрогнозувати найбільш пріоритетні та
найбільш затребувані
специфікації специфікацій, беручи до уваги
зміни, які ми очікуємо відбутися в
цій країні, тому
першим е-е-
е
найпріоритетнішим буде кваліфікація для
будівництва  і е-е-е,
сектори відновлення, е-е, ця секунда буде
гм-спеціалізацією та е-мм спеціальностями
для транспорту та логістики, є 14 е-
мм
кваліфікацій, вони
також розглядають
майбутню гм-мм євроінтеграцію України
та інновації та нові
технології - це те, що буде потрібно,
незважаючи на  той факт, що ви можете просто
позичати або купувати технології в інших
країнах, але ви не можете
купувати або позичати робочу силу для роботи
з цими новими технологіями та
інноваціями, і вам потрібно навчати цей
робочий курс, ось чому
український рух до
Європейського Союзу  вимагають
посилення
вимог до робочої
сили з точки зору того, щоб вона була
більш екологічною, більш
кваліфікованою, більш ефективною тощо.
вторгнення, з того моменту,
коли стало зрозуміло, що Україна
зміниться, і пояснивши вам
загальну логіку
архітектури проекту, тобто
прогнозування майбутнього розвитку
ринку,
зосередженість на
пріоритеті, професії, орієнтація,
близька орієнтація на  ринок праці
тощо
на цьому слайді ви бачите конкретні
заходи, розроблені для
реалізації цих цілей, тобто ми
збираємося
вимірювати не кількість заходів, які
проводить проект, а кількість
людей, які пройдуть навчання  і перепідготовка
в центрах у
центрах професійної підготовки, і ми вважаємо, що
такий підхід дозволить нам
посилити зв’язок між
центрами підготовки та перепідготовки та
ринком праці та спростить для
людей сприятиме плавному переходу
робочої сили з одного
Інший важливий аспект –
це підтримка наших партнерів.
Стратегічна підтримка наших партнерів. Будь-яка
освіта – це майбутнє,
і в нашому першому блоці ми збираємося
відповісти на виклики, які існують у
цій країні,
відповідаючи попиту на робочу силу
ринок хм у нових
кваліфікаціях, а також запити
від учасників бойових дій від колишніх
учасників бойових дій та навчання
дорослих, хм, зараз ви можете побачити два
блоки хм до компонентів хм, звичайно,
можуть бути додані деякі інші ммм, наш досвід
роботи в цій країні  на поточні
обставини та наш досвід
реалізації проекту свідчить про те, що
сьогодні ми маємо створити передумови
для подальшого розвитку нового розвитку
канікулярного
навчання, друге, що ми дізналися, це те, що
розвиток країни –
це розвиток її
людей, і я заохочую вас
приєднатися до роботи над проектом і
якомога більше долучитися до нашої діяльності, щоб
створити передумови для нашої майбутньої
Перемоги дякую за увагу дякую
за ваші презентації ви можете
взяти свої гм сидить ну як було
сказано у проекту не було багато часу
для широкомасштабних досліджень, але я сподіваюся, що
проект буде мати багато
можливостей для розширення для
розвитку кваліфікації, ми
чули про чотири компоненти
проекту від пана Пола та пана Алекса, і
ці чотири компоненти схожі на ті
чотири  головна природа е-е Сила природа для
es, які існують у природі, і зараз ми
збираємося провести панельну
дискусію гм, де ми
обговоримо наступні запитання,
чому надання навичок для відновлення так
важливо зараз під час війни, які
три першочергові кроки необхідні для
підготовка кваліфікованої робочої сили, як би
ви хотіли активізувати вразливі групи
для
процесів відновлення, це не моя роль
модератора, щоб втручатися в
порядок денний, але щодо третього пункту,
я б запропонував трохи виправлене
формулювання,
як,
ні, як  ти хочеш, але як
ти думаєш, що можна
активувати, це не умовний режим,
а фактично ствердний спосіб, що
ми повинні це зробити, чи
потрібна нам ця сімка, гм,
крісло Сімки, добре, в цьому
випадку я залишуся  тут і буде продовжувати
рухатися, що створить
певні труднощі,
Форлан, добре, тепер додано четверте крісло,
і це ще один приклад того, як
ситуація
швидко змінювалася весь цей час, тому для обговорення
оголошеної теми у нас буде майже
ціла година  наприкінці сесії я
приділю 15 хвилин сесії запитань і відповідей,
а для коментарів аудиторії
я радий запросити пана Рамана
Понскі, директора сектору
зайнятості з Міністерства економіки Європи
пана Міссена Шума, голову V
директорат е-е Міністерство освіти і
науки Міс Хана Резнік Заступник голови
від uh nqa е-е Пан Денис Ален Заступник голови
державного центру зайнятості М Дін
Вербицький директор і Jo cers і міс
Наталія Заріт Голова
НУО ще
добре, у мене немає крісла, ми будемо
сідайте там,
добре, кожен із вас, оскільки учаснику дискусії буде
надано п’ять хвилин для
вступної
промови президента та 30 секунд до
закінчення вашого часового інтервалу, я попереджу
вас, а перш ніж це зробити, я пропоную
вам  витратити лише 30 секунд, щоб
відповісти на мої запитання, ну, ну, українською мовою
йдеться про початок проекту,
тоді як англійською це означає kick off um the
project,
тобто гострий обід чогось, що
має бути атаковано, щоб сказати, що має
бути викинутим з проектом
відповідати назві я
хотів би спочатку викинути дані,
тобто звернутись до даних і
щоб зрозуміти, чи
успішно ми реалізуємо проект
і чи хотів би це
е-е, кидайте виклик старому підходу,
старому традиційному чи традиційному підходу
в наших навчальних закладах і
фразі, яку ми робили так протягом
століть, і впроваджуємо зміни, дякую, ем,
я вважаю, що ми повинні кинути виклик
спілкуванню, тому що всі проблеми
виникають через погане
комунікація, гм, усі добре
знайомі з
байдужістю на
адміністративному рівні, яку ми маємо
змінити, що ми маємо консолідувати наші
зусилля, щоб отримати результат, якого ми
хочемо досягти, я вважаю, що ми повинні
змінити наш підхід до  запроваджувати нові
технології та
щоб досягти результатів добре, ми
почали, а тепер
давайте по черзі виступимо з нашими
вступними
промовами,
пансі, давайте почнемо з
обговорення першого питання, чому
навички для відновлення?  це так
важливо зараз, під час
війни, на мій погляд, це не дуже
складно, ви можете
пригадати цю історію, коли в
джунглях сходить сонце,
починає рухатися лев, а антилопа —
ідея полягає в тому, що незалежно від  хто
ти в джунглях, коли сонце
сходить, ти маєш почати рухатися швидко,
і це говорить про те, що незалежно від
зовнішніх умов ми маємо
рухатися швидко та робити щось, ми
очікуємо, що післявоєнний ринок праці
буде рости і вимагатиме від вас  робоча
сила е-е-е, і ця праця за робочу
силу повинна буде відповідати
вимогам ринку праці та
кваліфікації, а люди з найбільш
затребуваною
кваліфікацією зможуть зайняти
гідні посади на ринку праці,
щоб дозволити людям отримати
ці гідні посади ми маємо запропонувати
перекваліфікацію
цим
людям [Музика], наше завдання
полягає не лише в порятунку людей, які перебувають
у важких життєвих обставинах, а й у
порятунку цієї країни, і ми можемо об’єднати
ці дві цілі
серед пріоритетних заходів, щоб
швидко  перепідготовка кваліфікованих працівників – це
про мікрокваліфікації та
переосмислення кваліфікацій, у мене ще є
п’ять
хвилин, далі нам потрібно буде створити
центри підвищення кваліфікації, і
роботу в цьому відношенні виконуватиме
міністр економіки, і ми
попросимо е-е мін.  освіти та науки та
національного кваліфікаційного агентства, щоб
допомогти нам у тому,
що ми будемо переглядати систему,
оновлювати її,
оцифровуючи все це, включно з
інвентаризацією, наразі немає більше деталей,
але плани
є, і третє питання, цей третій варіант, ну,
як  щоб краще підтримувати
вразливу групу, щоб змусити їх
краще брати участь у процесі відновлення,
дозвольте мені дати вам назви деяких професійних
програм, які ми вже маємо, і ми
будемо розширювати [
Музика]
їх, щоб у нас була армія
відновлення, це не законодавче право
мова, але це скоріше про
запрошення та працевлаштування
безробітних на роботу
на прохання військової адміністрації рівня OAS,
і вони також працюють над
створенням оборонних ліній та утриманням
міст, далі у нас є програма, яка
дозволяє micr надавати гранти на 250 000 Ґрівусів
підтримка працевлаштування, і ми
маємо близько 4000 таких грантів
на загальну суму близько 1 мільярда G, які
вже
видані приблизно вночі тому
Кабмін видав постанову допомогти
роботодавцям з обладнанням робочих місць для
людей з обмеженими можливостями, тобто роботодавець
готовий когось найняти  з
обмеженими можливостями зможуть отримати
підтримку від уряду, щоб облаштувати
робочі місця для таких людей, щоб
вони могли працювати
краще, дякую, Роман, ну,
пан Понскі просто окреслив, не
просто окреслив загальні перспективи, а
й навів кілька прикладів, які спонукають
інших наслідувати  suit shik your 5
minutes так, дякую, е-
е, я пригадую ситуацію, десь
років сім років тому, коли я працював у
відділі освіти в
Ністі, я пам’ятаю, коли ми намагалися поговорити
з компаніями, просячи їх
спільно переглянути наші програми, щоб  почуйте з
цього, що не відповідає їхнім
очікуванням, і ви пам’ятаєте, як люди
казали нам, що ми в порядку, все гаразд, у нас
достатньо персоналу, у нас достатньо речей,
нічого не можна
змінити з поточної точки зору,
я впевнений, що так, нам доведеться робити
прогнози  і ми повинні обговорювати, чи зможемо
це робити щоразу, щоб не сказати, що ми можемо
кожного разу правильно прогнозувати, але це
окупається, тому що, повертаючись
до мого прикладу років тому, через два роки
одна з цих
компаній звернулася до нас і повідомила, що  у
них залишилося, майже всі
з початком війни виїхали за
кордон, а компанія гостро потребує
роботи, тому
для нас це справді проблема, тому що ми
переживаємо війну під час воєнного
стану, і ми
Жодна країна в
сучасній Європі пережила обставини,
але, як зазначив MRO, позитивним моментом
є те, що ми не зупиняємося, ми
рухаємося далі, і навіть у таких
складних обставинах ми намагаємося зосередитися на тому,
що може чи має статися пізніше
деякі з цілеспрямованих результатів цілком
зрозумілі та очевидні, тому що нам доведеться
відновити, відновити нашу країну, що
ми вже почали робити, е-е,
далі нам доведеться подумати
про
е-е, відновлення економіки, щоб вона
знову дихала, е-е, щодо конкретних секторів
це скоріше
питання для міністерства економіки, але
знову ж таки йдеться про правильне прогнозування
того, що потрібно зробити, і я думаю, що ідея
проекту полягає в тому, щоб надати підтримку
Україні деяким вибраним особам, щоб
побачити, що країна  отримав якраз
потрібну кваліфіковану силу,
і нам потрібно підготуватися до B, навіть якщо ми
програємо з деякими нашими прогнозами, якщо ми
маємо щонайменше
80% правильний прогноз, це все одно
створить міцну основу для
досягнення Україною розвитку  і
перспективи зростання, які він стягнув з нього, інакше
все наше існування та всі наші
зусилля будуть
марними. Звідси цінність проекту
для
всіх, ну, якщо говорити про прогнози, Іна,
а ми, мені здається, вони
здебільшого базуються на  на деякі
наукові розрахунки я не знаю
швидкість вітру тощо або у вас можуть бути
якісь е-е, ви знаєте, просто природні явища,
які деякі люди намагаються використати, щоб
передбачити погоду чи є у вас якісь
природні явища, ви можете судити про свої
подальші дії, дозволяючи  я, ну, розповім тобі
історію моєї
мами, ну, вона також завжди
казала б мені, що ключові природні
явища, якщо Сонце сходить,
усім пора вставати і йти на роботу, я
думаю, що це ключове природне явище
слідувати, добре, дякую, Хан Реснік,
заступник голови національного
кваліфікаційного агентства, це мені
трохи нагадує український knock
as knock naft, який має національного
нафтогазового оператора, але точне uh neck
або natural qualification agency
англійською – це інша історія, але це
підкреслює  важливість вашого
енергетичного
агентства, так, дякую вам, дорогі колеги,
питання, які ми сьогодні обговорюємо,
надзвичайно важливі для всіх, ми
розуміємо, що
майже 2 роки ми живемо в умовах війни,
і це вплинуло на всі аспекти
нашого
життя.  багато збитків і проблем
все ще, на жаль, будуть наростати протягом
певного періоду. І це велике
питання, як ми маємо підтримувати
країну, її економіку і в першу чергу людський
капітал, який ми маємо, говорячи про
професіоналів, е-е, кваліфікованих працівників, ми в
першу чергу маємо на увазі знання, навички,
компетенції, речі  які є ще
важливішими та потрібними сьогодні для і без
того вразливого ринку праці тут, я
думаю, усі погодяться, що держава
має отримати підтримку вже
зараз, час минув, але багато чого було зроблено,
і все ж в умовах, коли багато
компаній і підприємств знаходяться в  Руїни
з багатьма людьми, що залишилися без роботи з
втраченими документами, - це складна ситуація, що
законодавство надає
можливості визнати
кваліфікацію роботи в, що носить голови
мого агентства, це стосується кваліфікаційних
центрів, я маю на увазі, що це
надають можливості навчання та вони
вони можуть
визнавати грантову кваліфікацію також на
основі навчання та освіти за
кордоном, результатом чого є сертифікат
від кваліфікаційного центру, і це
відкриває можливість працевлаштувати
власника сертифіката, а це допоможе
наситити ринок праці кваліфікованою
робочою силою та  З повагою будь-яка охоча
особа, я звертаюся до такого кваліфікаційного
центру з проханням
підтвердити свою кваліфікацію та оцінити її
центром, за умови, що
кваліфікація
вказана в
реєстрі професій, і це, безумовно, відкриє
можливості для працевлаштування для такої
особи.
Функціонування кваліфікаційного центру є
відносно новим, тому що вся
система почала існувати наприкінці
2022 року, але ми вже бачимо, що це
дуже ефективний механізм
виходу людей на ринок праці, у
реєстрі кваліфікацій, який ми маємо,
вже згадується 42 кваліфікаційні
центри по всій Україні  що вже працюють
із визнанням
кваліфікацій,
загалом 155 професійних кваліфікацій,
і майже за два роки ефективної
роботи кваліфікаційних
центрів,
приблизно
16 100 таких сертифікатів
вже видано, не найсвіжіші
дані, ми збираємося отримати
оновлену статистику в  це питання кількох днів,
але кількість 1600
сертифікатів уже є надійним ключем до того,
що ці люди працевлаштовані або
вже працевлаштовані, тому кожен, хто
цікавиться відповідними стандартами та тим, як
працюють кваліфікаційні центри, може звернутися до них, і наше
агентство готове надати
методологічна
підтримка для подальшої
розробки стандартів кваліфікації, і
він готовий проконсультувати з будь-якого питання,
що стосується цього, готовий до
співпраці, велике спасибі, і ваш
прогноз на найближчі дні, принаймні, якщо
говорити про економічну та трудову погоду,
тут дуже приємно чути і
послухайте заступника директора державної служби
зайнятості Деніз
Оленик, дякую
з самого початку Я хотів би подякувати JZ
за співпрацю та підтримку з
2021 року завдяки підтримці GS
ми змогли
підготувати близько
50 педагогічних кадрів  для наших
центрів ми також отримали підтримку в
натуральній формі у вигляді інформаційного та іншого обладнання,
ми змогли навчити близько 200 годин
членів у 2020 році
два ми отримуємо регулярні поставки
нашого добре інформаційного обладнання, ноутбуків
тощо, включно з деяким спеціальним
обладнанням для наших  навчальні центри
включали зварювальні
станції обладнання для авторемонтних майстерень
навіть дрони та сільськогосподарське
обладнання занадто багато рядків, щоб згадати
їх тут, але знову ж таки це допомагає нам
адаптуватися до поточних викликів, і ми
робимо все можливе, щоб трансформувати наш
сервіс відповідно до сучасних
вимог, як Роман  Міністерство
економіки згадало, що у нас є цілий ряд
національних програм, наприклад, micr, гранти,
250 000
гра, ваучери на навчання для ветеранів війни,
близько 20 000 таких вур уже
роздано, ми не розуміємо
ситуації на
ринку праці, ми бачимо, що до
7% безробітних – це
жінки, які перебувають у списку та зареєстровані в нашій
службі. Офіційно ми маємо сотні
4000 безробітних,
але ми змінюємо наші
технології, ми намагаємося більше працювати з
роботодавцями, ми намагаємося надсилати
до них лише вмотивованих людей
на основі їхніх  прохання, тому що ми вважаємо,
що лише мотивовані люди працюють
найкраще. Наші центри забезпечують навчання
для понад
12 000 близько 8 000 безробітних, які проходять
навчання у роботодавців,
і ми не розуміємо, що коли наші
ветерани повернуться з
передової, їм знадобляться обидва
Служба підтримки та перепідготовки та зайнятості
повинна буде допомогти їм у
соціальній адаптації в плані допомоги в
пошуку
роботи, щоб вони були справді адаптованими та
готовими до мирного відновлення
нації, дякую Денисе, я не сумніваюся,
що реабілітація та  ветерани
будуть у виступі Наталія зітка
але на відміну від ет урядових структур
Представники давайте послухаємо
голову СОС незалежний ну
безпартійний Сан
вербицький так дякую ми працюємо
над проектами розвитку всіх рівнів
Регіональний Національний і якщо говорити чому  нам
потрібна кваліфікована військова робоча сила. Я б назвав
гідністю намір людини
відчувати гідність мати можливість сказати всім
і собі, що так, я
працевлаштований, я дбаю про своє життя
і можу забезпечити гідне життя собі
та  моя
сім’я, ми також знаємо, що 71% тих, хто
живе в Україні, готові змінити
роботу, і я вважаю, що завдання, одне із
завдань проекту, полягає в тому, щоб надати цим
людям можливість робити саме це, перекваліфікувати їх, перекваліфікувати
їх, надати їм необхідні
Навчання Дозвольте мені зараз зосередитися на деяких
важливих речах. По-
перше, це стосується
системи збору даних і
показників, це дуже важливо для
системи
для загальної політики зайнятості, яку
впроваджує уряд, для
роботи Національної
служби зайнятості, це веде до подальшого  уточнення
та вдосконалення даних, які ми збираємо, щоб
краще знати, чому люди вибирають
або не вибирають це в Україні, як
люди будують кар’єру, як змінюються погляди та
очікування ветеринарів, це
вплине на наші подальші втручання та
подібні проекти в
майбутньому  ще одне питання, про яке слід згадати, — це
гендерна рівність, тому що
розташування професії та навчання є саме тією
частиною освіти, де
можна побачити найменший гендерний баланс, і це можна
і потрібно вирішувати відповідною
державною
політикою, починаючи зі шкіл, тобто до того, як
люди йдуть до ну це
школи  над цим потрібно попрацювати,
нам потрібно побачити, як
працювала система професійного навчання та навчання протягом
останніх
років, е-е, деякі з останніх років відправили
багатьох із нас на дистанційне навчання, і це
навіть посилилося з початком
повномасштабного
вторгнення та питанням  чи
втрачають люди частину своїх навичок, працюючи
дистанційно чи дистанційно навчаючись, і
наскільки вони відповідатимуть вимогам ринку праці,
коли вийдуть із
мережі. Наступним є питання
психологічної допомоги та консультування.
Це тема, яка широко
обговорюється та використовується в  практично в кожній
установі,
оскільки дуже важливо бачити, що люди
можуть отримати ці консультації, і
така освіта має бути безбар’єрною, щоб
зробити її рівноправною та позбутися однієї з
проблем, з якою ми,
безсумнівно, зіткнемося в
країні, коли  ми думаємо, як
держава повинна вирішувати
проблеми безробіття та зайнятості, відразу
розуміємо, що у нас є
широкий спектр хороших програм для
вирішення цієї проблеми, але
нам потрібно більше уваги
приділяти навчанню та
перенавчанню, особливо професійній
перепідготовці, ви згадали
програму ваучерів, і я вірю в це  це дуже
корисно, що дозволить людям отримати
доступ до короткотермінових
програм перепідготовки, щоб отримати нові навички, знайти
гідну роботу, і економіка
країни буде рости, оскільки ринок праці буде
задоволений, а попит на ринку праці
буде задоволений
шановні колеги,
якщо дехто з вас вважає, що те, що було
згадано byan
verbit, сказано не повністю, я б
порадив вам
веб-сайт центру Seas,
де ви знайдете більше інформації, і
врешті-решт я радий надати слово
Міс Наталія Заріт, яка не просто
голова
Ste жінка, вона також серце цієї
організації, дякую Андре за цю
презентацію хм, вперше я зустрів Андре в
хегу, де Андре був модератором нашої
дискусії
про викрадених е-мм-
мм військовополонених у  у цій війні я
дружина України українських військовослужбовців,
які
воювали на багатьох фронтових гарячих видах спорту, в
тому числі станом на Санкт-Петербурзьку
та на
південно-західній територіях, коли він був звільнений із
військовополонених, а потім
звільнився з армії  Служба
і одразу стала гм, безробітною
людиною, у вас є досвід
стрілянини з вогнепальної зброї, і ви знаєте, що
є
гм, е -е -е, назад назад, коли ви
робите стрілянину з вогнепальної зброї, і
ми очікуємо, що ми отримаємо такий ударний шоковий
удар  після війни,
коли сотні тисяч
ветеранів війни повернуться до мирного життя,
це було
в
Сполучених Штатах, коли 90% цивільного
населення мали на вулицях SE бездомних,
вони припускають, що це були колишні
ветерани війни  тож давайте уявимо
ветеранів війни, які повернуться з
передової, це будуть люди, які
бачили смерті, які стріляли
роками й роками, які переживали
стрес, які були або поранені, або
ув’язнені, як і в’язні, і просто
Уявіть, що ці люди повернуться
додому, і ми повинні
зрозуміти, що реабілітація не може
відбутися протягом двох тижнів у
лікарні з
ще вісьмома ветеранами війни в тій самій
кімнаті, тому реабілітація ми повинні бути в змозі
запропонувати належне відновлення  Реабілітація для
цих
людей, тоді майте на увазі, що
буде величезний попит на нову
армію, щоб виконувати
завдання з відновлення в країні,
але людина — це не машина,
і ви можете просто змінити перемикач
з е-е  стрілянина в армії в
нові хм
трудові обов'язки і
багатьом ветеранам війни важко хм
пристосуватися до
умов мирної праці в компанії
не хм уявляти як вони
хм залишаться за партами в
класах
хм просто  уявіть собі ті
потенційні конфлікти, які можуть
спалахнути в аудиторіях, де ви будете
збирати для перенавчання ветеранів війни
та
людей з колишніх окупованих
територій та/або тих, хто відмовився
йти на передову, і це
потенційно небезпечна ситуація, так це
тому я дуже вдячний J за те, що
хто підтримує такі проекти
[Музика]
хм, звертаючись до реалій сучасної
української
бюрократії, хм, у створенні реєстру
ветеранів війни, що ветерани війни
мають доводити свою історію, хм,
долати всі
громіздкі бюрократичні етапи
підтвердження статусу ветерана війни
ну хто ветеран війни це люди
які або лежать на лікарняних
ліжках або вони в ровах на
передовій в окопах на
передовій ну це або
учасники бойових дій або дуже психологічно
та фізично вразливі люди,
і ви повинні навчити їх зараз, давайте
уважніше подивимось на
безбар’єрний підхід, тож уявіть цю
людину з обмеженими можливостями,
яка має психологічні та фізичні
рани та може отримати доступ  до
освітніх
служб, і я досить часто згадую
фразу зі списку Шиндлера: ви
не можете врятувати весь світ, але ви
можете врятувати деяких людей, і роблячи це,
ми повинні надати можливість отримати
освіту для деяких людей, ну,
це неможливо  врятувати весь їхній
світ, я думаю, це неправда, у тих
людей, які вижили під час Голокосту,
вони мали гарне прислів’я, врятувавши
одну людину, ти врятував увесь світ,
і насправді ви чули сьогодні, як
Наталя Зітка та десятки тисяч сотні
тисяч  члени сімей члени
комбатантів,
вони вижили через цю реальність
війни, і тепер я планую попросити
спочатку міс Шумі, а потім пана
Понскі прокоментувати те, що ви почули,
і аудиторію також
запрошуємо  приготуйтеся публікувати запитання,
ну, мені було приємно, що
ще у 2014 році я працював у
новому діпропетровському
обладміністрації, коли ми зіткнулися з
першими колишніми ветеранами, які
повернулися з передової, і я повністю
згоден з цим  ви не зможете врятувати
їх усіх, але ви зможете
допомогти принаймні деяким із них і тим
уразливим групам, тим членам
уразливих груп, яким вони знадобляться не
тільки
гмммммммммммммммммммпотрібне більше
усвідомлення того, що  буде доступним для
них, тому що ті, хто буде більше
обізнаний, вони зможуть отримати дві три
послуги такого типу, наприклад,
санітарні послуги,
послуги відновлення здоров’я три рази на рік,
тоді як менші особи про цю можливість
не отримають  те ж саме
стосується освітніх послуг і
професійної підготовки,
крім того, у сучасному світі
ви можете очікувати абсолютно
несподіваних змін і негативних
змін щодня, і вони пропонують нам
бути гнучкими, і ми маємо  бути
доброзичливим, доброзичливим до ветеранів,
доброзичливим до всіх людей з
особливими потребами, і це нелегко, тому що
ми не були
готові до потреб у
реабілітації, як
описала Наталія,
ми так само не готові  хм
отримую величезну хвилю хм колишніх
ветеранів війни я теж мав такий досвід хм
коли ми
приймали хм дітей з
окупованих територій, яких привезли
на українську територію, і в тому ж
літньому таборі у нас були діти, чиї
батьки були учасниками бойових дій з українського
боку  на передовій і ті
діти, ну ці дві групи
дітей, між якими був внутрішній конфлікт,
один постійно казав, що це
через твоїх батьків, що наші батьки
мають воювати на передовій, а
інші діти продовжували казати, що ми приїхали
з окупованих  територій, і ми
хочемо бути інтегрованими в Україну,
це говорить про те, що всі програми для
ветеранів,
гм, не будуть просто правильно чи
гарно організованими програмами,
але вони матимуть багато
нюансів, ще раз хороший приклад із регіону Netos
один із наших тренувальних центрів знаходився на
деякій відстані від транспорту
та логістики, і один із ветеранів,
який мав подолати цю відстань, і
для них це було проблемою, йому довелося
протестувати проти цього, і це говорить про те,
що в майбутньому  у нас може бути багато таких
випадків, дякую, Ірена, а тепер
слово за Раманом, а я нагадую,
що ті, хто дивиться нас у Facebook, або
на YouTube, можуть писати
нам свої запитання, міністерство
економіки формулює  політика у
сфері зайнятості та всі суміжні
питання щодо зайнятості також знаходяться
в центрі нашої уваги. Вчора ми
провели зустріч з нашими іноземними
партнерами, і ці іноземні партнери були
трохи
здивовані тим, що в
Україні функції  Центральний
орган виконавчої влади, який мав займатися
питаннями та проблемами
ветеранів, ці функції розподілені
між кількома центральними органами виконавчої влади,
а щодо міністерства
економіки ми
співпрацюємо з кількома ветеранськими
організаціями,
і разом із цим
Партнерством ми намагаємося внести зміни в  і
змінити чинне законодавство та
спростити для ветеранів війни
інтеграцію їхньої інтеграції в
мирне життя,
і гмм, існує величезна кількість
питань, ммм, охорона здоров’я,
освітня проблематика, працевлаштування, і
міністерство
економіки
також має свої
документи, що
регулюють  потрібен необхідний рівень
знань у
сферах безпеки праці та
достатня професійна підготовка,
і ми намагаємося вирішувати
проблеми та вирішувати їх належним чином,
звичайно, існує величезний спектр
проблем, які ви згадали, але цей
елемент має бути  з’їдені по частинах, і
ми повинні почати
щось робити один за одним. Наталія має
коментар, ви маєте рацію, віце-прем’єр-
міністр щодо реінтеграції,
закликає до консультативної ради, але
деякі
міністерства створюють перешкоди для
цієї роботи, але я хотів би  послатися
на
указ президента №
576, який встановлює новий порядок
перегляду щорічного перегляду
статусу
особи з обмеженими можливостями для проходження
військової служби,
тобто ви не зможете планувати
свою
підготовку  хм більше ніж на рік, і
ми очікуємо, що у нас буде
створене
суспільство хм ті, хто втік за кордон,
будуть проти тих, хто залишився тут, ті,
хто був би на передовій,
були б
проти тих, хто
хм залишився в році
гм  і завтра великою проблемою буде
рівень заробітку тих, хто зараз воює
на передовій, тому що вони заробляють багато,
але тоді
пенсіонери кажуть, що
це занадто одноманітно і занадто малі
зарплати, щоб я міг
там працювати, так, дякую і  у нас є
запитання з
місця, і просто представтеся, так,
збирався
kishka Інститут професійної
кваліфікації, і я маю запитання до
Анніка, статистика вражає 42
центри
професій 1600 уже
виданих сертифікатів, але була
фраза про те, що вони як
працевлаштовані  скажіть, що видача
сертифіката дорівнює
працевлаштуванню чи є у вас якась система для
контролю за цим у реальному житті,
і чи чули ви про будь-які проблеми
чи проблеми, про які повідомлялося в цьому
районі, дякую за запитання, коли
я говорив,
я зосередився на факті  що
сертифікат, виданий центром,
однозначно є дозволом на роботу, і звідси
людину можна працевлаштувати. Наше спілкування
з кваліфікаційними центрами на основі
щомісячних звітів і кількості
залучених сертифікатів
дозволяє нам зробити висновок, що
на це є попит.
що люди, які звертаються до кваліфікаційних
центрів,
крім того, можуть
працевлаштуватися, так, дякую, ще є
запитання з
місця, так, від цього пана,
будь ласка, і в мене є принаймні одне запитання, щоб
потім відповісти, так, Олександр
Шалюк минулого року ми брали участь у
проектах на основі GSZ на  професійна
підготовка та моє запитання, ймовірно, буде
е-е. B коментар від Arena Shumi, ви
глибоко поважаєте цей сектор, я хотів би
вам сказати, але я все одно хотів би зосередитися
на певному колі питань і почути
вашу думку щодо цього, ви знаєте, ми
Минулого року було кілька успішних проектів,
серед яких були проекти Дж. У
нас є проекти, реалізовані
USAID та іншими подібними
організаціями, і здається,
що кожен раз, коли вони починають з нуля, про
що
кілька разів згадувалося до  необхідність
збільшити результати, результати.
Питання полягає в тому, як міністерства
освіти, науки та економіки
беруть участь у
забезпеченні впровадження результатів проекту,
а не
починати щоразу з нуля.
Так, дякую за ваше запитання
Насправді, ми були б раді повідомити про
багато таких проектів, насправді їх не так багато, у
нас був дуже успішний
успішний проект, з новим повним
навичкам на робочому місці,
який розпочинається ряд
короткострокових спільних тренінгів  з UNP
і
usate, і це справді короткострокові,
спеціально призначені для внутрішньо переміщених осіб і
тих, хто був звільнений від
ветеранів військової служби, тому це не
секретна формула, досить стандартна,
скоріше, коли проекти Le з роботодавцями
розробляють на основі цієї
програми навчання та  запрошувати та
зараховувати людей, які бажають продовжити роботу, тому це
не принесе 100% працевлаштування, але це
нормально, тому що люди можуть переїхати
кудись із своїми нещодавно набутими
навичками в пошуках кращих
можливостей щодо
обміну досвідом, ви знаєте, ми завжди із задоволенням ділимося
інформацією з  нові майбутні
проекти Мені самому не подобається перебувати в
ситуації, коли все потрібно починати
з
нуля, але насправді це підводить мене до
гарної ідеї, що ваші коментарі в комунікації слід
розташувати за столом, щоб поділитися
досвідом, який ми вже отримали та зібрали,
дякую  ви, Арена, будь-яке
інше запитання з залу, якщо не моє
запитання до вас,
Наталі, ви згадали про
чоловіків у своїй промові, але тим часом у нас є
жінки-ветерани, і там буде більше представників
обох статей, як
ви згадали,
наприклад, чоловіків, військовослужбовців і там
один
Біцкі також згадав про аспект гендерної рівності,
тож так, у нас є жінки на передовій,
деякі з них сильно вийшли заміж, візьміть
Адріану Сусак, вона була головою
ветеранського руху, вона була справді
важко
поранена, і волонтерам довелося шукати
можливості для  повернути її до життя,
справді, це вимагає підходу до
окремого підходу до жінок, які постраждали
від війни на
передовій, також додати сюди роботодавцям
не варто боятися
ветеранів, звичайно, є і
будуть деякі нюанси, деякі проблеми, але
ці  є та можуть бути подолані в
обмін на те, що ви отримаєте
професіонала з глибоко розвиненою
інтуїцією з блискавичною
реакцією та здатністю
виконувати е-е, ви знаєте, що ці хлопці здатні
відчувати сповіщення про рейд, які надходять, ви знаєте,
справді за півгодини до
сирени  тож ми можемо лише уявити, що
дівчина
жінка, яку природа навчила
народжувати, щоб бути матір’ю, щоб зберегти сім’ю,
я думаю, що буде ще багато сильних
моментів, які потрібно відкрити, і просто е-е, коротке
зауваження щодо жінок не лише ветеранів-жінок-
солдат, а й просто  Жінки в
регіонах існує широко поширена ситуація
в областях, коли багато чоловіків мобілізовано до
армії та місцевих компаній. Підприємства
відчувають брак робочої сили, і це
змусило нас рекламувати деякі
раніше традиційно чоловічі
професії для
жінок. У Миколаєві є компанія,
яка оголосила, що має  оголосив
курси навчання водінню трактора для дівчат, традиційно вони
пропонувалися лише для чоловіків, тому один із
результатів цієї
війни, дякую, Арена, і наш час для
цієї панельної дискусії добігає
кінця, бо ми збираємося рухатися далі,
і ми маємо  за дві хвилини до того, як ми почуємо
від одного з інших наших учасників
усю дорогу з
Івії, настав час для вас
згадати кілька найбільш пам’ятних слів
у цій дискусії, у кожного з вас
буде 30 секунд для цього, і ми почнемо
з Van verbit
uh the  час у Європі після воєн
Друга світова війна Друга світова війна
створила поштовх
до
політики боротьби з
безробіттям, іноді у країн не було
інших варіантів, окрім як розробити речі, які
зараз для нас очевидні, як-от надання
допомоги по безробіттю,
служби зайнятості тощо, ми будемо  у тій
самій ситуації, де ми будемо
шукати інноваційні варіанти для вирішення
проблем, з якими ми стикаємося, і
ключове слово - це
турбота, про яку ми говорили
ініціатива, дякую, ваші 30 секунд
закінчилися Денис Елен,
наступний,
щоб зауважити зауваження Наталії, ми на
роботі  служба чітко
розуміє ситуацію, яка у нас
з
ветеранами, до якої ми
звертаємося [Музика], і ми розуміємо, що
наші співробітники повинні бути досить гнучкими,
надаючи Послуги, у нас вже є
програма грантової підтримки ветеранів, у нас
уже близько 300 заявок
за такі гранти від ветеранів, які бажають
розпочати свій
бізнес, дякую, Деннісе Роман
Пінскі, робота може бути
порятунком, а щоб отримати роботу, щоб працевлаштуватися, потрібно пройти
навчання, тож давайте тренуватися,
давайте розвиватись і давайте
не
залишатися в
блюзі,
я думаю, що відновлення було  найбільш
модне слово сьогодні, і воно вимагає
різних
компонентів із того, що ми чули
сьогодні, ми безумовно повинні об’єднатися заради
спільної
мети, кожен із нас має власне
бачення того, як потрібно вирішувати проблеми,
щоб прийти до  спільний знаменник, ми
маємо регулярно зустрічатися, щоб обговорити
проблеми та шляхи їх вирішення, дякую,
можливо, не так помітно, але мені
подобається слово слово виклик Мені не
подобається слово проблема чи проблема Я хотів би
виклик на сайт від
Петро  знову посилаючись на пана Калада з обласної
адміністрації зайняті руки ніколи не бувають
без діла Наталія
Б Сьогодні вранці я зв’язалася зі своїм чоловіком і
сказала йому, що йду на цю дуже
важливу
подію, і він сказав, що ти будеш говорити
про державну політику та ставлення
до  обслуговуйте мене, будь ласка, скажіть
їм, що особливі люди мають
підходити таким чином, щоб вони
більше не відчували себе такими
особливими, дякую, що підводить
риску під цією дискусією, і
ви можете повернутися на свої
місця в  у кімнаті буде
обговорення цього під час перерви
після заходу, головне те, що
ми розпочали цю
роботу, тому ми
продовжуємо роботу, і ми відчуваємо, наскільки важлива міжнародна співпраця,
ніж цей проект  фінансується та
підтримується Німеччиною та
uh GS, що дозволило нам почути Ель
Біган, керівника департаменту
Міністерства освіти
Льва, і вона розповість про свій
досвід і про те, як латва бачить
Україну, ми всі
чуємо, доброго ранку, шановні колеги  Для мене
велика честь і приємність, що мене
запросили виступити перед цією поважною
аудиторією. Дякую, тільки
невелике виправлення. Я не керівник
відділу, я старший експерт, але,
тим не менш, маю досить великий
досвід роботи в Міністерстві
Освіта та наука Льва також до того
часу, коли Латвія перевищила ЄС, а
також зараз, і окрім цього, у мене є
ще одна роль. Я також дослідник в
Університеті
Льва, займаюся, зокрема, ветеринарними
дослідженнями, а крім того, я також член
кількох  Робочі групи ЄС щодо
ветеринарної медицини, а також Консультативний комітет з
ветеринарної медицини, е-е, і в 2020 році 21 я мав щасливу
нагоду працювати разом з
українськими колегами щодо їхньої
реформи, особливо
рамки кваліфікації, і, незважаючи на досить критичні зауваження,
кажучи, що
я ще маю працювати,  я дійсно був дуже
вражений роботою, виконаною до цього часу в
Україні, е-е, з того, що ми могли стежити в
цій роботі, я можу сказати, що Україна
справді йде майже пліч-о-пліч з
реформами та розвитком ЄС там,
е-е, тому мене тут немає  пораджу вам,
як діяти, а я тут, поділюся
своїм досвідом, як ми рухалися
після виходу з ЄС, і як
проходять наші реформи, і, можливо, кілька хороших
прикладів, які можуть виявитися
корисними, тому ми приєдналися до e у 2004 році
і негайно
змогли розпочати використання
привілеїв Європейського структурного
фонду, а саме Європейського
фонду регіонального розвитку для
інфраструктури та обладнання та
Європейського соціального фонду розвитку людського капіталу
щодо Європейського
фонду регіонального розвитку одразу в той
час, коли я був головою
підрозділ структурних фондів ЄС, ну, ми могли уважно стежити за
всіма процесами, які ми плануємо, почали
планувати реконструкцію нашої школи в
2004 році, і лише зараз я можу сказати, що минуло майже 20
років, усі наші школи
були реконструйовані, добре обладнані,
і ми дуже пишаємося цим  наші
сучасні ветеринарні школи, які
в деяких випадках навіть більш популярні, ніж освітні
загальноосвітні школи, тому що ви знаєте, що це
великий виклик у всій Європі, мають
престиж цих
шкіл, оскільки Європейський соціальний
фонд ми розпочали нашу V змістову реформу, і
вона має прямий  ну, посилання на те, про що сьогодні
колеги говорили про те, як
залучити компетентних людей до минулого ринку праці,
а також як зробити їхні навички
сумісними з потребами
та
розвитком ринку праці, і я повернуся до
змісту незабаром після цього, але
головне питання  Реформа полягала в тому, щоб
перейти до
підходу, заснованого на компетенціях, який має
прямий зв’язок із мікрокваліфікаціями
чи обліковими даними, як згадував сьогодні один із вагомих
доповідачів, тому що
таким гнучким способом ви можете вирішувати
проблеми ринку праці в  це найефективніший
спосіб завершити нашу реформу
змісту, яка знову зайняла понад 10
років, лише минулого року ми отримали
поправки до закону V. Самі поправки —
це 19 сторінок
самих поправок, де ми
включили все, що стосується цієї реформи.
зміст 10-річної модулярізації,
мікроакредитації та все, що робить
ринок праці дуже гнучким, доступним для наших
студентів. Я не буду розкривати ці
деталі, тому що
я хотів би сказати ще кілька речей.  на
найвищому рівні у нас є Рада з питань зайнятості,
де три відповідні міністри
зайнятості, освіти та економіки збираються
регулярно, як правило, раз на місяць, і
вони виявляють, що обговорюють усі
відповідні питання на ширшому політичному
рівні, але всі ми запровадили
інституційні
механізми нижче  вирішувати ці
питання на кожному рівні практично, ми
пишаємося, тому що наш соціальний діалог не
тільки на папері, як це іноді трапляється,
але це насправді в реальному житті. Іншою
важливою інституційною формацією є
Рада з освіти дорослих, яка на
національному рівні справді займається всіма
питаннями освіти дорослих або  на
ринку праці, і зараз нашим головним пріоритетом є
індивідуальні облікові записи для
кожного працевлаштованого працівника, але ми все ще
на шляху до цього, ми ще не завершили
це, як я вже сказав, ключем до нашої реформи є
підхід, заснований на компетенціях, який дозволяє
будь-якій людині  ринок праці
з незначною кваліфікацією, і тепер наше
завдання полягає в тому, щоб зробити це в цифровий спосіб,
все оцифровано, і,
звичайно, ми дуже пишаємося
Рамками кваліфікацій секторів, де кожен
сектор нанесено на карту горизонтально
та вертикально, і кожна людина може  подивіться
його або кар’єру, починаючи з найнижчого
рівня кваліфікації eqf 2 до кваліфікації eqf 7,
і це робиться в тісній
співпраці з нашими партнерами ринку праці,
це не освіта, це справді
місце зустрічі для освіти та
працевлаштування, але просуватися вперед із
моєю презентацією
тому наші школи справді дуже
сучасні, добре обладнані, ми маємо дуже гарний
зміст, тому ми дуже щасливі та
задоволені, якщо українські колеги
захочуть організувати якісь навчальні візити, е-е,
ми завжди можемо це організувати в міністерстві,
але зараз я хотів би звернутися до  один
приклад, е-е, який є одним із пріоритетів
цього проекту, і він стосується
вразливих
груп, е-е, і будь ласка, дозвольте мені в
заключній частині мого короткого втручання
торкнутися одного конкретного проекту, який
ми ніколи не очікували, що дасть такі хороші
результати, назва проекту
pumers це абревіатура, тому що повна
назва щось на кшталт um запобігання
відсіву з програм професійної підготовки
студентів із соціально
вразливих груп абревіатуру pumers було
створено, на мою думку, дуже мудро, тому що в
lvan це означає щось на кшталт зв’язку,
щось потенційне, що
потенційно  може розкритися чудовою
квіткою, цей проект розпочався п’ять років
тому, виявляється, ми чи не
єдині в Європі в Європейському Союзі, хто
має такий проект Національної політики,
і він надзвичайно успішний, його
навіть представили Європейській
комісії та багатьом  багато країн
зацікавилися, яка стать
успіху проекту, але, звичайно,
ми не в такому вразливому
становищі, як зараз Україна, але все одно
в Львові є багато молодих людей,
які є соціально незахищеними, і цей
проект зробив чудовий  було створено
методологію, як у кожній
школі Львова звертатися до цих молодих людей, але не
лише до цих молодих людей, а й до
вчителів, і є дві важливі
речі, перш за все, вони розробили
методологію та на основі інтерв’ю вони
зібрали інформацію, які типи
ми маємо вразливих студентів, і
виявилося, що є чотири великі
групи, наприклад, ті, хто має
матеріальні проблеми, ті, хто має, скажімо,
сімейні соціальні проблеми, ті,
хто пережив травматичний
досвід, є чотири групи, і
залежно від цього вони розробили
методологію  як вирішити проблеми
чи виклики кожної з цих груп,
по-друге, існує тренінг для
вчителів і групових наставників, які не
викладають, але справді сьогодні допомагають
цим учням вирішити їхню проблему в
будь-який час доби, а вчителі
оновлюються та підвищуються  спеціальними
програмами, а також на основі конкретних
випадків розробляються нові програми
або короткі курси, але, що важливіше
і справді, я хотів би звернути
увагу на цей інноваційний
досвід, цей проект у співпраці
з телебаченням Lan розробив близько 15
програм на
телебаченні, де було  кожна записана на
певну тему, наприклад, життя
без батьків, знущання в школі, е-е,
нещасливе кохання, навіть це є проблемою для
молодих людей, як ви розумієте, що може
перешкодити вам працювати добре, а потім у
цих програмах молоді люди з таким
досвідом
добровільно дозволяють їм бути
Вчителі також були залучені,
коли ці програми показують на
національному телебаченні, перш за все
це бачить вся країна, а
потім у школі вони можуть
це обговорити, і це надихає
молодь, тому що
перш за все вони бачать, що вони не самотні зі своїми
проблемами, можливо, про них соромно
говорити, або іноді вони настільки напружені, що
не можуть говорити, і це
чудовий терапевтичний ефект для цих
людей, щоб ці молоді люди могли
не кидати, наприклад, через
якісь психологічні чи особисті
проблеми, я не буду вдаватися глибше, але ви
можете мати інформацію про цей
проект, а також команда проекту
відкрита для обговорень або навіть для
семінару, можливо, якщо вам буде цікаво
поділіться
досвідом, але я можу сказати ще одну
річ, яка, можливо, навіть важливіша
як дослідник. Я дізнався, що
Університет Львова проводив дослідження
цього проекту, і вони опитували
не лише цих уразливих студентів,
звичайно, з їхньої згоди, а також
цілеспрямовані групи вчителів, які працюють
зі студентами, і результати
цього дослідження та інтерв’ю були
абсолютно неочікуваними, тому що метою
цього проекту проекту Європейського соціального фонду
було справді запобігти
відсіванню та допомогти тим молодим
людям, які перебувають у школі.
у дужках поступаються звичайним студентам ветеринарної медицини,
тому ми повинні допомогти їм,
щоб вони або стали принаймні
рівними, або не кинули навчання, і результати
цих співбесід є абсолютно
несподіваними для всіх.
Виявляється, що дуже багато з цих уразливих
студентів починають робити  набагато краще,
ніж так звані звичайні студенти, а це
означає, що цей дуже успішний
проект не лише запобіг їх
відсіванню, але й зробив їх
успішними студентами під час співбесід, коли
ви запитуєте їх, яка допомога вам потрібна більше,
вони відповідають, що у мене є все, немає допомоги
потрібен просто все залежить від мене самого,
і я маю великі ЦІЛІ в житті. Я хочу
стати підприємцем. Я хочу мати
власну компанію та подібні відповіді,
чим цим я хочу сказати, що це була
цілеспрямована добре затребувана політика щодо
допомоги незахищеним студентам  і їхні
вчителі та прихильники можуть творити дива,
якщо це могло статися в Львові в ситуації,
коли ми не перебували в такій
ситуації, як зараз в Україні, якби це було
дуже корисно Я Я Я Я Я вірю, що, можливо,
Україна може мати
для них якийсь цікавий досвід, можливо, щоб допомогти  щоб вони
звернулися до своїх студентів, які перебувають у
дуже вразливій ситуації, як ми
розуміємо, і наприкінці моєї
презентації чи короткого виступу я
хотів би ще раз подякувати вам за запрошення
за можливість поділитися
та висловити думку  наші
колеги з міністерства, що якщо ви
знайдете якийсь досвід Івана цікавим або
корисним, ми завжди відкриті, щоб поділитися
матеріалами з нашими методологіями, а також
готові до деяких навчальних візитів, і якщо деякі
люди в Україні можуть бути зацікавлені,
дякую, дуже дякую, міс
Буїг  ви говорили про дуже
серйозні речі, але іноді
у вашому голосі та на вашому обличчі була посмішка, і
для мене це знак впевненості,
що те, про що ви говорите,
матеріалізується, ми в Україні вдячні
народу Ітії за  вашу постійну
підтримку та
солідарність, і ми зробимо все можливе,
щоб ви знову посміхнулися цього разу, дякую,
удачі цього разу про наші
успіхи Бережіть себе, дякую, міс
бу, а тепер настав
час дати слово міс Тані
Белеті, яка  є керівником відділу
підтримки реформ в Міністерстві освіти і
науки
України, ага, я отримав сигнал, що
Тана не VI Zoom Тана тут присутня
фізично і, що
найголовніше, аудиторія готова
дивитися в цьому
напрямку  ой, дякую за цю
можливість, учора мене запитали мої
колеги,
хм, вони запитали мене, які були
для мене головні виклики. Мені подобається це
слово, виклики, які мають найбільш
позитивний і негативний відтінок
водночас, з
2019 року я  працював у команді
підтримки реформ у Міністерстві
освіти і науки, і весь
цей період я брав участь у
розвитку
освіти V uh та співпраці з
міжнародними партнерами, і, на мою думку,
один із викликів є
обопільним  розуміння, а
також важливості бути на
одній хвилі щодо пріоритетів і
необхідних змін менталітету у
сфері навчання під час канікул, чому я
навчився, е-е, в умовах війни
багато процесів значно
прискорилися, наприклад, е-е,
розуміння  важливість
навчання та перепідготовки V в контексті
освіти дорослих радикально змінилася з
початком повномасштабної війни, багато
підходів до V
змінилися, і більше того, я хотів би
вказати на таке поняття, як
інклюзивність в освіті
в Україні, досить часто  ми розуміємо як
інклюзивність гм вразливих
людей, але
гмм переважно людей з обмеженими можливостями, але
мммммммм я вважаю, що ми повинні змістити
акцент з ммммм інвалідів на
гмм людей з різних маргінальних груп
від людей у ​​складних життєвих
обставинах до тих, хто є ВПО  хто
є мігрантами до Європи, хто є
ветеранами війни тощо, на мій погляд,
це досить важливий зсув, який
важливий не лише для України, а й для
європейських країн, тому що після
Другої
світової
війни та після Другої світової війни у ​​них
не було  не було такого
досвіду для Західної Європи
після першої світової війни, гм, ці
витрати були відсутні, тому з
точки зору Німеччини та
західноєвропейської точки зору вони
дуже зацікавлені в утриманні українських
мігрантів, щоб перекваліфікувати їх
і  хм, щоб прийняти їх як нову робочу
силу, тоді як для України природно
повернути українських мігрантів і
перекваліфікувати їх
хм, хм,
навіть маючи на увазі майбутній
вступ України до ЄС, що
це ставить перед вами нові питання, хм, нові
перспективи  ярлика Ринок це
всі аспекти, про які ми повинні
пам’ятати обговорення всіх проблем
taana um у мене до вас два запитання ми
багато чули про
інклюзивність освіти, але я мало
чув про інклюзивність
роботи чи інклюзивність
Ринок праці Я вважаю, що це безпосередньо
пов’язано з інклюзивністю
професійної
підготовки, коли ви говорите про
професійну підготовку, що ви маєте на увазі, як
називали в моєму радянському
дитинстві
професійну
підготовку, так, ви праві, але
Вимоги на
ринку праці змінюються швидко і швидко, а
потім війна продемонструвала це досить
яскраво, а
компанія виявила необхідність
адаптувати свої навички до зміни
життєвої ситуації якомога швидше,
війна запровадила ще гостріший
попит на  і ми з’ясували,
що ви не можете вчитися навичкам
усе життя, і вам потрібно отримувати
нові навички, і я вважаю, що
ми багато чого навчилися на цьому
шляху, я не кажу про
інклюзивність праці  ринок я
говорю про результат
ринку праці так би мовити люди які
отримали які отримали нові
робочі місця а потім дискусії про
повернення українців і формування
робочої сили а це не
міграція з України яка була
часто обговорюється, і ми повинні взяти
це до уваги, і, незважаючи на
війну, умови життя в україні
залишаються привабливими для деяких людей з
Азії навіть зараз. Я не експерт у цьому,
але я
пройшов навчання
міжнародної праці  організація у
сфері праці марських мігрантів, і
в результаті цього навчального курсу я
краще зрозумів, чому деякі
країни навмисно привозять робочий
капітал з інших країн з тих
країн, де умови ну
гірші, є класичний
приклад Німеччини  яка невдовзі після
другої світової війни відкрила двері для
трудових мігрантів, і я вірю, що для
України це також буде вихід, і
на початку презентації ми
побачили цифри і ми зрозуміли,
наскільки люди нам
потрібні, у нас величезні  територія, і
багато людей старіють, і у нас
буде багато людей з обмеженими можливостями, і
це буде виклик для
освіти, щоб визнати
освіту мігрантів з азіатських
країн і навчання іноземною
мовою та іншим  аспект
інклюзивності Інші питання
інклюзивності чи потрібні нам додаткові
платформи для обговорення цього питання дякую
Тана е-е Тана є керівником
відділу підтримки реформ Міністерства
освіти і науки та М Лін з
[Музичного]
Посольства Німеччини, пані, шановні,
дорогі жінки  і панове, шановний Андре, пане
модераторе, для мене велика честь
бути тут і передати вітання від
Посольства Німеччини з побажаннями
успіхів проекту в найкоротший
термін. Німеччина підтримує Україну
з початку
Незалежності та підтримує реформи
різні аспекти українського життя
почалися задовго до
початку війни повномасштабне
вторгнення 2014 рік, коли почалася фактична війна
за Русь проти України на
сьогоднішній день Німеччина була
серед найбільших
донорів і країн, які надають Україні
політичну
підтримку весь цей
час
the do Gaz shaft for internal
виріс і став добре визнаним
інструментом такої співпраці в
Україні та з Україною завдяки величезному досвіду за
плечима, і Jette зміг
заслужити
довіру та звітувати від українського
уряду про українські компанії та
бізнес  люди з
громадськості, тож тепер ми знаємо їх, як тільки що
сказав Г. Це говорить про те, що всі знають
цей дуже важливий інструмент
німецької технічної допомоги Україні,
ми всі знаємо, що
бюрократ бюрократичні процедури
вимагають часу, але в цьому випадку дивно,
як швидко  Досвідчені зусилля
полягали в тому, щоб підготувати проект разом
з Ukrainian C Parts. З того, що
мені сказало керівництво проекту, ми маємо отримати
деякі перші результати до кінця цього
року, щоб звітувати,
і більшу частину бюджету
проекту потрібно  бути витраченим
якнайшвидше, це великий прорив
для німецьких проектів із
середньою тривалістю життя від 3 до чотирьох
років. Андре, ви запитали про те, яке
українське прислів’я може спасти
людям на
думку, і приблизно переклали
український PRT
– старий ніколи  хреститься,
доки не пролунає грім із
неба, і, ймовірно, це може бути пов’язано з
фундаментальними змінами, які відбулися в
Німеччині, також щодо допомоги
Україні з
точки зору безпеки та того факту, що JZ, який
швидко реагував на
зміну потреб у  Україна також у
сфері професійно-технічної освіти та навчання,
це показує, як все може швидко
змінитися. Справді важко
виступати останнім, тому що всі
практично все згадували, а з
іншого
боку, він усе ще хоче
подумати та сказати щось важливе.
Дозвольте мені спробувати,
тому технологічний прогрес за
останні десятиліття призвів до появи нових професій,
нових робочих місць, нових ринків і підприємств,
і
це було рушійною силою розвитку
для більшості європейських
країн, що змушувало їх починати з
U навчання протягом усього життя
відповідного досвіду е-е в
Європейські країни, що входять до G-сімки,
накопичилися за останнє
десятиліття чи
близько того. Потреба в такій
освіті існувала ще до того, як
країна, а Україна є сучасною країною
з економічно розвиненою
економікою, і ви можете побачити, наскільки ми просунуті,
ви можете перевірити  Ваших iPhone ви можете
побачити проникнення цифрових
технологій тут, а іноді потяг
йде вперед із своїми процесами порівняно
з багатьма країнами, включаючи
саму Німеччину, тоді блискавка, яка
вразила це, трапилася ще у 22 році, що
підкреслило потреби в навчанні впродовж життя,
необхідність залучення idps до
ринку праці на регіональному ринку Лаосу,
щоб реагувати на зміни, і це буде
одним із ключових моментів цього проекту.
Я впевнений, що проект стане благом
не лише для українських, а й для
німецьких та європейських професіоналів, яким є
чому
навчитися  там рушійні сили здебільшого
продиктовані технологічним процесом, а
тут рушійною силою є кризова
ситуація, судячи з
попередника ЄС щодо проекту навичок,
досвід дуальної освіти, коли
роботодавці залучаються до
професійної освіти
Німеччина має цей досвід найгірший
буде дуже корисним для використання в
Україні, і з того, що я чув, цей
досвід буде далі досліджуватися та
вивчатися протягом цього
проекту.
Нарешті, я хотів би окреслити цю дуже
важливу співпрацю між двома
українськими міністерствами – економіки та
освіти  і наука, я
можу вам сказати, що в Німеччині не так просто
об’єднати кілька
міністерств над одним
проектом, і ми маємо тут купу
проблем в Україні, починаючи від ВПО і закінчуючи
потребою C для потреб
військовослужбовців  з
уразливої ​​групи, і це, безумовно,
привертає увагу
міністерства реінтеграції, міністерства у
справах ветеранів,
ще більше, що попередні доповідачі
згадували про важливість вивчення
долі ветеранів війни, і, безперечно,
це виходить за межі сфери та сфери
відповідальності лише одного  або навіть
пару міністерств, тож є чому
повчитися у німців у німецьких
професіоналів, і є речі, яких
українські однолітки також можуть навчити своїх
закордонних однолітків,
останнє, але не менш важливе, це
питання повернення українців до
рідної країни  Я хотів би запропонувати
ширший погляд на це, нам потрібно побачити, як
українці повернуться до професійного
життя, просто візьміть приклад, ну,
академічні
дослідження, багато дослідників не можуть
продовжувати свої дослідження через
пошкодження інфраструктури, деякі з них
виїжджають за кордон і, до речі,  не
кожен з них зміг знайти
там можливість працевлаштування, якась держава на соціальну допомогу, інші
були раді знайти іншу роботу, не
пов’язану з
дослідженнями, тим часом це означає, що
це призводить до ситуації, коли
такий потенціал
просто втрачається для
країни  і це втрата мізків не лише
через витік мізків, тому питання
повернення людей до їхнього
професійного життя дійсно має значення, і
цей проект, який пропонує нові
можливості кваліфікації
перекваліфікації також для дорослих з
попереднім
досвідом освіти, які знають, що, можливо, вони мають
середню  або вища освіта, навіть
докторський ступінь під поясом, тож
знову ж таки мова йде про те, щоб дозволити людям
повернутися до продуктивного
життя, тож повернемося до вашого
запитання чи до того, що ми знайшли як
ключове слово для цього ключового ключа для цієї
стартової зустрічі, тож це питання
відродження трудових ресурсів в Україні,
повернення їх до професійного
життя. Я думаю, що я встиг на це лише деякий час,
добре, дякую, дякую, Міо, і це
саме той час, коли я знову повинен попросити М.
Пауло
розірвати та підвести межу
Кілька останніх слів, і я прошу вас
бути такими ж корисними та спокусливими, якими ви
були на початку між вами, я
сподіваюся, що у вас усе гаразд, хм, дякую
за ці напружені дві години та
дискусію, з якої, я думаю, ми почали
обговорювати пологи  Вимоги ринку, гм, ми
обговорили вимоги до
системи професійно-технічної освіти та навчання з питань праці, ми детально обговорили
потреби в роботі з уразливими групами,
а тепер ми трохи обговорили
міжнародний погляд на те, що ЄС має
зробити на своєму шляху, щоб стати ЄС
держава-член, гм, я маю лише три короткі
повідомлення для вас, перше —
проект розпочато, моя команда буде
наполегливо працювати, щоб розпочати роботу не
пізніше 1
листопада, і ми раді працювати
з обома міністерствами разом і з
20 V навчальними закладами, я думаю, що
другий пункт um diito zagari, згаданий
у його промові,
викликає величезну міжнародну підтримку, і я
просто хотів би ще раз оголосити,
що ми, як виконавець німецького
уряду, також  готовий до
співпраці з іншими державами-членами ЄС
та іншими країнами, третій
і останній пункт
для мене більше особистий висновок, дякую, Наталія, за те, що
ви згадали про
компетенцію EXC, я також визнав, що
потрібно мати справу з цією групою
особливо  під час моїх візитів у Vin та
Pava, гм, ми намагаємося зробити все можливе, щоб
інтегрувати потреби в нашу проектну
діяльність, ми будемо навчати вчителів, як
працювати з уразливими групами, ми
підтримаємо фінансово навчання
в наступному місяці, і ми будемо
також навчати консультантів з питань кар’єри, але те, що я
зрозумів з обговорення, це те, що
є ще багато чого, що потрібно зробити, це стосується
сфери медицини, ортопедії, ну,
лікування, це стосується сфери
психологічної підтримки, і, звичайно, ми
працюємо в Програмі освіти та навчання,
і ми  ми обмежуємо себе та намагаємося
включити якомога більше, але
ми також маємо ширше портфоліо,
наприклад, медичну підтримку тощо,
і я б підтримував зв’язок з
іншими організаціями та намагався знайти
з ними зв’язки, тому що я відчуваю, що це
завдання для покоління, і воно вимагає
не лише співпраці між
різними міністерствами та урядовими
установами в Україні, а й величезних
міжнародних зусиль, щоб керувати
цією інтеграцією EXC бойовиків, а
також інших уразливих груп, таких як
ВПО, дякую, я хотів би
вас запросити  нарешті до
зустрічі з мережею, гм, ми пропонуємо обід, хм,
ще раз дякую, і ми залишаємося на зв’язку дякую дякую
велике спасибі M дякую
всім за те, що ви тут за
участь, я хотів би також подякувати
rusan
за організацію  редагування відео.
Я хотів би подякувати Андре за
звукорежисера, і наприкінці восьми я
хотів би сказати вам, що
в обох версіях навички для
відновлення згадуються без пробілів
або, як кажуть, наша робота Метро
проміжки між
їх
і далі ви можете побачити, що є
також деякі слова, зібрані
разом, написані без потрібних пробілів,
що
означає, що немає часу марнувати, давайте
зосередимося на тому, що ми робимо, дякую, дякую,
і, говорячи про
Україну,
прислів’я, удачі
e